-Guys, whenever I get some
downtime here at the show,
I like to go on Instagram
and I just scroll through
all the photos.
That's how I do it.
My downtime, I'm just like...
I've got a touch screen.
Yeah, a big touch screen.
I got the new iPhone 16.
Suckers are about yea big.
-Really? Two hands?
-Oh, yeah. I'm just like...
I'm like, "Hello.
You're on speakerphone.
When are you not
on speakerphone?"
'Cause the speaker
is so big on the phone.
So, anyhoo,
I got the 16 mini, though.
So it's about --
It's about yea big.
So, I flipped through Instagram
just going like,
"Oh, yeah, yeah."
I feel like, you know,
Kornacki over there.
And one thing I've noticed --
that, a lot of times,
two people will write
the exact same caption,
but the pictures they post
will be completely different.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
I'll show you what I mean
in this next segment.
It's time for "Picture This."
-♪ Picture this, picture this,
picture this ♪
♪ Yeah, picture this ♪
-Alright, let's take a look at
this first example of
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris both
wrote, "Bright things ahead."
Joe Biden posted a picture of
Kamala as the first female VP.
Kamala Harris posted
a picture of
Joe Biden's teeth.
See, it's the same caption
but different things.
Yeah, like,
this next one is from
the Trump campaign
and also Tim Cook.
They both wrote, "Lose one,
and it's all over."
Trump campaign posted
a picture of
the swing states.
Tim Cook posted a picture of
AirPods, yeah.
You lose one...
-It's all over.
-Here's one from Quibi and
Claire of "The Bachelorette."
They both wrote,
"Damn, that was fast."
Quibi posted a picture of
Claire.
Claire posted a picture of
Quibi.
Here's one from Stacey Abrams
and Steve Kornacki.
They both wrote,
"Let's do this."
Stacey Abrams
posted a picture of
the Georgia run-offs.
Kornacki posted a picture of...
his bed and a bottle of ZzzQuil.
What's the difference with
ZzzQuil and NyQuil?
Because when I drink NyQuil,
I ZzzQuil.
-Yeah, I think ZzzQuil
helps you get your Z's.
-What does NyQuil do?
-It's the nighttime, sniffly,
sneezy, coughy, head --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you get paid?
Are you a paid spokesman?
I mean, why not just take --
Doesn't NyQuil make you sleep?
-I mean, not me.
But ZzzQuil --
talking some serious Z's.
-E's?
-Z's.
Well, that's E-qual.
Comes in a little packet.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Sugar substitute. Yeah, yeah.
E-quals. Yeah.
Moving on, here's one from...
[ Laughter ]
E-quals.
Here's one from a dog and a cat.
They both wrote,
"I love him and worship him
and would do anything for him."
Aww.
The dog posted a picture of
his owner.
The cat posted a picture of
Satan.
-Yeah, that's about right.
-Yeah.
-Here's the last one here.
It's from Governor Cuomo
and Melania Trump.
They both wrote,
"Two more months, tops."
Cuomo posted a picture of
outdoor dining in New York.
Melania posted a picture of
her marriage license.
There you go.
That's all the time we have for
"Picture This."